where the [ __ ] is helix swam away some
people say he's still swimming to this
day right or a sea horse I think I
shaked him I think I shook him up guys
all right skewers the rotten roll point
put on your role-playing hat because
it's about to get steamy it was Friday
Friday morning the date 13 Oh No
the date was unknown but I did know it
right we don't know who struck first but
we do know how does it start here we go
dad Higgins Haven 1984 there were five
four six boys and a girl and one girl
her name was Maria Oh Marta dad and Vic
superb say having a campfire what am I
gonna do send you the background I'm
here for some views maybe Ken could I be
nappy deep a video I try to run to the
cabin for him or what they didn't know I
had a great [ __ ] ass I decided to
entertain the cabin and then play the
piano
hey my jacket is actually in this game
how about they oh oh ho ho [ __ ] you oh
yeah hey oh Jesus Christ whose day good
day good day to you milady
no close the door you crazy Mexican lady
you [ __ ] do it [ __ ] all right you
stay by the door and make sure it's safe
all right we should all do the safest
thing and go upstairs and had that
always seems to work I'm the ghost of
Christmas past I [ __ ] hear you in the
game dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing
heal me my ass haha thanks for killing
us right away oh thanks for killing me I
appreciate that what the [ __ ] are you
doing to my body well yeah well y'all go
and come on back I found the car oh my
god I got a weapon ah [ __ ] I wasted it
directions you want to go my Christmas
tree oh my god you killed him bunch of
Yankee my body of Jesus Christ oh well
it kind of sucked ass not to be so hello
is anybody hello hello hello is anybody
out there
all right I it's your boy you wanna kiss
boy all right where should we take
alright what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] no
any pain is anyone doing hi how's it
going in there
are you the guy are you the gardener
these hedges need to be trimmed sir si
Senora
my father is very rich howdy and I don't
what the [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
[ __ ]
I'm out of here oh [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
white ass in alright where are the rest
where are you guys somebody's in a barn
I mean I don't know that you're a
[ __ ] girl hey then surprise
[ __ ]
did I kill you that killed you what the
[ __ ] surprise [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] ah Jesus
[ __ ] your shitty car this is not a Volvo
where is he now
[Music]
hey what can I do for you 6x I think I'm
going to talk you to dad please much
you'll never find me much I'm hungry
my [ __ ] face why are my eyes just
popping out of my [ __ ] face crazy
Murthy I think I shaked him I think I
shook him up guys I finally found Felix
and his friends and I killed them all
now I'm going to go home and make a
lotta meat pasta and make a video about
he subscribed her yeah Jimmy what's up
give me a hug how you doing baby [ __ ]
sake we can't even feel the flow is it
so important so you have finally come
waving me bread oh my [ __ ] god you
[ __ ] Jesus Christ okay are you guys
working on this car the same one where's
the where's the battery there yeah does
anyone know probably at the barn we're
just gonna have to spread out and look
how do you find a battery oh my god
let's get out of here
wait let's run it over or lesser memory
where's my addiction
[Music]
you can't come in the roadtrippers
promise we're going to trim out if you
attract the car I'll buy a new one
hey might see it there's there's there's
a bug behind you damn it God God you
can't [ __ ] kill Jason what are you
talking
keep looking it's like a lot of friends
hey you don't have the mask anymore show
it look at me oh my god Marcel you're
beautiful I pop the phone come to me
okay beautiful a Romanian clearly woman
I will go with you oh Jesus let's call
the sheriff Jack septic it's this tick
tick tick at five minutes we're gonna
survive five minutes gasps oh Jesus
Kenneth's repla kill him not me tell him
the killer Romanian killer Romanian get
the romantic and the cats are coming
hallelujah we're saved can we can be
together
we have mercy
that's a cop the cat save me caps
[Music]
posture enemy bars are for your dead
corpse and that's the story how my
girlfriend went [ __ ] crazy
I hope you enjoyed this story of time
with parents please do watch another
video right though here it's gonna be
even better than this one click it now
or else something might happen it's
going to text me oh ok
watch it
[Music]